[Music]
bianca's with us in boston hi bianca how
are you
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so my husband and i are on baby step two
and we've paid off all of our debt
except for my student loan which is the
largest part of our debt i have uh i was
gifted about six thousand dollars or it
was about three thousand at the time so
it's more than doubled in size an
investment account when i graduated from
high school and i'm trying to figure out
if i should take that out or if it will
be too hard in tax implications to take
that out or if i should just leave it in
there
you should take it out and pay off your
debt
okay
how should we plan for paying the tax
off on that at the end what's it
invested in
it's just invested in mutual funds so
it's in a general brokerage account it's
not a requirement where did you get it
you put in where'd you put in the 3000
i was gifted to you
yeah so my grandparents had gifted it to
me as a high school graduation gift and
they put 3 000 of cash in at that time
or was it an account they already had
it was cash that they put in for me at
that time all right so your basis in
this is three thousand dollars anything
over three is going to be taxed at a
capital gains rate of 15
and so that's 450 dollars if your gain
is if your total is six thousand so your
gains three
times fifteen percent is 450 bucks
okay
so just set aside 500 extra in your
savings account so when your tax bill
comes a year from now you'll be ready
and use the rest of it for your debt
okay yeah that's a lot less than we
expected so that's a
uh hopefully that's
that's not too bad yeah that's going to
be it because you're it's a long-term
capital gains you've held it longer than
a year when you receive a gift your
basis in the gift is what the person
paid for it which in this case was three
thousand dollars and so your gain is
anything over the basis
and that is the gain is taxed at 15 on
long-term capital gains i'm not a tax
expert but that is the right answer you
can double you can double check it with
an actual tax expert the math that you
can do in your head dave ramsey i just
can't i still can't i'm like oh my gosh
just
what i don't know i don't know it's just
quick math just fast math we grew up
with t9 calculators in my day we had to
we got we got a calculator i did see
that meme the other day which is really
funny
which one it was like the uh
take this 90s teacher the teacher's
standing up going
someday you're going to be in a
situation where you don't have a
calculator they're like taking a test
and he's like holding his iphone going
no yeah that's right that's right i'm
not i'll never be in a situation where
there's not a calculator there's always
a calculator i'll never be in a
situation where there's not a camera or
a flashlight i've got them all right
here at all times
that's so true it's so true i'm crawling
around in the parking garage last night
with the flashlight looking for your
mother's iphone who had dropped hers out
of the car in the parking garage so yeah
you've always got a flashlight you know
it's just you know you've hit your six
it's like it's like macgyver it's like
macgyver you know you've got your little
trick your little swiss pocket swiss
army knife right here all built in it's
so off subject but there has to be
something
true about like the neurological part of
your brain when you grew up having to do
math in your head you know what it is
actually flex that muscle doing the show
for 30 years okay so i can't i can't do
real math i can do big math
yeah round numbers yeah i can do round
numbers really really fast so you'll
hear me round stuff
and hit close sure okay but um and i
used to run the calculator in the old
days i'd have it sitting here yeah when
i first started when i first started the
show but i got to where i just got
impatient with that and you could just
it but it's a muscle you just learn to
do it it's like memory yeah you'll be
able to do it in a couple minutes i know
i know
i don't know i feel like i have to like
right now fifteen percent okay fifteen
three thousand point
bumping up a little bit there you go
there you go that's not bad or as we're
talking about we'll get to a call james
james like y'all shut up uh or dave math
dave math is like
dave's like you're going to have a
billion dollars at age 65.
i'm like i don't know if that's right
that's called dave math
oh dave matthews exaggeration math and
you have dave math okay dave math
it's funny funny all right
let's just keep moving